i know in science whenever i say
something's impossible i didn't wake up
the next day and say no that's actually
wrong i mean there are there are some
limits of course um i don't see myself
traveling fast and light any time soon
but eric weinstein says that's possible
so he will say europe sure but i'm an
experimentalist as well so one of my i
have two super powers and my
stupidity and i don't mean that as a you
know i'm like absolutely completely
witless but i mean my ability to kind of
just start again and ask the question
and then do it with an experiment i
always wanted to be a theoretician
growing up but i just didn't have the
just didn't have the intellectual
capability but i i was able to think of
experiments in my head i could then do
in my lab or in that you know when i was
a with a child outside and then those
experiments in my head and then outside
reinforce one another so i think that's
a very good way of kind of
grounding the science right well that's
the nice way to think about
theoreticians is they're just
people who run experiments in their head
i mean that's exactly what einstein did
right but you were also capable of doing
that in the head in your head inside
your head and in the real world and the
connection between the two
is when you first discovered your
superpower stupidity i like it okay
what's the second superpower oh your
accent or
that well i don't know i'm my i like i
am genuinely curious so my curious so i
have a you know like everybody ego
problems but my curiosity is bigger than
my ego so as long as that happens i i
can i can that's awesome
that is so powerful you're just dropping
some powerful lines so curiosity
is bigger than ego that's something i
have to think about because you always
struggle about the role of ego in life
and
that's that's so nice to think about
don't think about the size of ego the
absolute size of ego think about the
relative size of ego to the other
the other horses pulling at you and if
the curiosity one is bigger then uh ego
will do just fine and make you uh fun to
talk to
you